[Musique]
avec plus de 400 sites militaires
répartis sur le territoire le ministère
des armées fait partie du quotidien des
Français au cœur des grandes
agglomérations comme dans les zones
rurales tout notre territoire est
irrigué par la présence militaire
dans ce numéro du journal de la défense
nous parcourons la France dans le Var en
Normandie en Alsace et dans l'Aveyron
nous irons au cœur de nos régions à la
rencontre de celles et ceux qui
dynamisent les territoires programme
d'envergure projet d'infrastructure
réhabilitation de sites militaires lien
avec la population nous verrons comment
l'action du ministère des armées
dynamise et pérennise la vie de nos
territoires
direction le sud au cœur du territoire
le plus militaire de France en termes
d'implantation connu pour son climat
estival et sa façade maritime la région
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur compte plus
de 2000 entreprises partenaires de la
défense
rassemblez autour de pôle d'excellence
allant du numérique à l'aéronautique en
passant par le naval c'est toute une
région qui vit au rythme de la défense
avec ses sous-marins ces portes
hélicoptères amphibie et le porte-avion
Charles de Gaulle Toulon est la plus
grande base navale d'Europe ici le bleu
de la Marine nationale se mêle au bleu
de travail de dizaines d'entreprises
mobilisées pour des besoins de recherche
d'innovation et d'infrastructures
c'est le cas ici sur la frégate le
Courbet
entrée au service actif en 1997 ce
bâtiment de la Marine nationale vit un
moment clé de son existence durant de
longs mois des travaux d'envergure vont
être menées pour y ajouter de nouvelles
capacités modification de structure
changement de lanceur de missiles
remplacement du système de combat une
seconde jeunesse qui permettra aux
courbée de rester à la pointe de la
technologie pour mener à bien ses
travaux c'est tout l'intérieur de cette
frégate de 125 mètres qui doit être
remodelée Frédéric et le responsable
technique il pilote la rénovation du
navire tous les jours il vérifie
l'avancée du chantier ici il fait le
tour de la frégate avec le commandant
adjoint opération du bâtiment et
l'industriel naval Group qui assure la
maîtrise d'oeuvre du chantier une fois
qu'il est posé quand est-ce qu'on
découpe les traverses pour finaliser la
mise en position de l'hélicoptère la
finalité des travaux d'intégration c'est
pour la fin de ce mois-ci donc toutes
les traverses sont enlevées qui
permettra d'accueillir effectivement
l'hélicoptère dans le hangar sur ce type
de chantier la coordination est
essentielle et les points d'états
réguliers tous veillent au respect des
délais au terme de 10 mois de travaux le
Courbet devrait retrouver le large à
l'été 2021
il faut tenir compte d'un environnement
contraint il faut tenir compte
effectivement de la structure qui est en
composite et pas en acier il faut
contenir compte des performances que
l'on doit conserver au niveau du système
nerveux donc il y a énormément de
paramètres à prendre en compte et tout
ça effectivement on s'appuie sur des
architectes on a un naval group on fait
valider bien évidemment ça par les
autorités donc non c'est pas simple des
chantiers comme celui-ci Frédéric en a
vu beaucoup à 15 ans il était ouvrier
sur le pont d'envol des porte-avions
Foch et Clémenceau
pour lui la clé de la réussite d'un
chantier comme le Courbet c'est la
planification un chantier c'est une
succession de problèmes qu'il faut
régler pour tenir les plannings c'est
surtout notre priorité c'est de que le
bateau soit opérationnel en juillet il
soit utilisable par moments pendant les
phases de démontage c'est une ruche ça
bourdonnée de partout aujourd'hui
effectivement nous sommes en période un
peu plus calme mais tout est relatif
parce que ce qu'on voit c'est plus calme
mais à l'intérieur ça travaille ça
travaille dans les ateliers ça travaille
dans les bureaux d'études ça se
reconfigure pour tenir le planning donc
on a 250 personnes jour présentes mais
c'est tous les sites de Lorient de Brest
de Paris de Toulon qui travaille pour
cette rénovation
un chantier d'envergure comme celui-ci
ne peut pas se passer de savoir faire et
de compétences techniques acquises au
fil des années par des prestataires
historiques de la défense c'est le cas
de la société de naval group sur cette
frégate l'industriel a sur l'ensemble
des modifications structurelles
dans le cadre de cette modernisation
d'ampleur des privates Lafayette il y a
trois grands domaines de transformation
on va toucher à la structure du navire
avec des modifications sur la coque du
bâtiment on va remplacer le lanceur
crotale par des lanceurs saddral on va
aussi remplacer le système de combat
donc on voit que ça touche beaucoup de
sujets à bord de ce navire et beaucoup
de compétences techniques on va
retrouver tous types de métiers on va
retrouver des coquiers des charpentiers
coques et qui sont capables de modifier
la structure du navire de souder on va
trouver des mécaniciens on va trouver
des électriciens des gens capables de
câbler et puis on va aussi trouver des
gens qui qui vont travailler sur le
système de combat sur les nouveaux
logiciels et qui vont les implémenter à
bord pour une personne qui travaille
chez naval group à Toulon à peu près ça
mobilise cinq personnes dans le Var ou
dans la région sud en plus on se rend
compte que un chantier de cette ampleur
là va amener à peu près 1000 empl ois
direct et indirects pendant la période
du chantier c'est à dire sur plusieurs
années compte tenu du fait qu'on se la
concerne trois frégates sur ce chantier
250 personnes interviennent
quotidiennement pour naval Group dont
une trentaine de sous-traitants parmi
eux des entreprises qui à première vue
n'ont aucun rapport avec le monde de la
défense à l'image de cette entreprise
d’échafaudage fondée en 1875 pour la
défense qui vous donne du travail elle
nous donne du travail en permanence et
depuis des années des années comme on
intervient sur tous les bateaux de la
marine française et aussi bien les
bateaux les sous-marins partout
au fil des travaux cette entreprise doit
installer démonter et remonter ses tours
d'échafaudage
sur le cours baie c'est sans dix tonnes
de matériel qu'il a fallu installer soit
l'équivalent d'une tour de 40 étages
Compagnon du Devoir Claude n'en est pas
à sa première expérience avec le monde
militaire
là on a monté un petit plancher
d'échafaudage pour des travaux de coq
donc on va on utilise l'échelle
existante pour descendre directement sur
l'échafaudage
et
ça c'est très fréquent très très grand
tout le temps par rapport à
l'environnement
chaque chantier est unique la contrainte
majeure reste la même mener sa mission
s'ennuyer à celle des autres
sous-traitants car il faut permettre la
continuité des opérations tout en
assurant la sécurité des agents
tu voulais pas la mettre plutôt dans
l'autre sens l'échelle
comme ça ouais mais bon ça quand les
mecs vont monter ils vont peut-être se
faire mal quoi
en parallèle différentes opérations sont
menées comme ici cette soudure de coq
sur mesure
pour la faire sortir
il y a un côté où il faudra chauffer et
la faire revenir
opérateur tuyauteur à ses débuts il y a
28 ans Grégory est aujourd'hui chef de
chantier au sein d'une entreprise locale
spécialisée dans la réparation et la
rénovation de navires de surface la faux
élèves marine sur ce chantier 17
opérateurs de cette entreprise
interviennent pour des renforcements de
bordée et des installations de nouveaux
blocs
pour le lestage pour laisser le bateau
en fait nous en vrai de la hauteur après
ils vont un briquet plein de lettres en
plomb en acier et tout on a fabriqué des
pièces à l'atelier là on les met à bord
et on est en train de les accoster de
dessouder
c'est pour ça ce qu'on vous disait c'est
la coactivité nous on travaille là il y
a qu'une échappée mais il y a des gens
qui travaillent sur les côtés donc c'est
pour ça qu'on est obligé d'aménager les
plages de travail que nous on travaille
l'après-midi les autres le matin c'est
compliqué Grégory fait partie des 50
personnes qui travaillent à quatre
kilomètres de là dans cette entreprise
de chaudronnerie Gilles accompagne 300
entreprises comme celle-ci dans la
région ce collaborateur du ministère des
armées et l'interlocuteur privilégié de
ces PME qui collaborent toute l'année
avec la défense allô Patrick oui c'est
moi c'est Gilles là je suis devant faux
élève et où est-ce que on se rejoint à
l'atelier bon d'accord
donc là nous sommes de les ateliers de
fausse élève marine qui est une
entreprise très importante pour la
rénovation des bateaux militaires
c'était l'entreprise civile et que je
vois tous les ans d'habitude mais là
tous les six mois avec la crise parce
que je fais on a une attention
particulière sur ce qu'elle fait et où
elle en est dans ses activités depuis la
dernière fois depuis 6 mois on s'est pas
vu on avait évoqué un petit peu les
maintenance des fruits
sur ces opérations là et que pour nous
c'est comme c'est vachement sécurisant
quoi tu imagines d'avoir un peu cette
visibilité là c'est vrai que quatre ans
de contrats dans les temps qui courent
c'est quand même assez fabuleux ça
permet de donner la visibilité de faire
des investissements de former les
personnes et encore 15 intérimaires
aujourd'hui donc moi je considère que
covid c'est un drame alors sanitaire
c'est évident mais sur l'aspect purement
économique pour l'instant j'estime avoir
été quand même pas mal privilégié en
étant dans ce secteur de la défense
c'est mon rôle aujourd'hui de contribuer
à la résilience de ce tissu économique
vraiment nous voulons un écosystème
d'économie de défense soit sain avec des
PME que je suis tout particulièrement
donc dès qu'elles ont un problème je
veux le savoir tout de suite pour
pouvoir réagir on a des outils au
ministère des armées et aux ministères
de l'économie c'est pour ça que j'essaie
de casquettes pour les aider à surmonter
ce passage difficile parce que on veut
pas que à une décision d'entreprise
tombe ça voudrait dire qu'un jour une au
frégate ne pourra plus fonctionner donc
ça il est hors de question de laisser
passer ça
si la région Provence Alpes-Côte d'Azur
constitue la deuxième région de France
en terme d'économie de défense il y a
d'autres territoires dynamisés par les
besoins du ministère des armées
en Normandie la base aérienne 105
d'Évreux et le premier employeur du
département de l'Eure implantée depuis
plus d'un siècle à 7 km d'Évreux cette
base aérienne était dans les années 60
une base de l'OTAN avec plus de 6000
américains et près de 80 avions de
transport aujourd'hui elle compte
environ 2000 aviateurs français 2021
sera une année charnière pour la base
elle accueillera l'escadron
franco-allemand de transport tactique
c130j cet escadron binational est une
première en Europe d'ici à 2023 il sera
composé de 10 aéronefs qui remplaceront
progressivement les mythiques C160
Transal au total ce sont 260 militaires
français et allemands qui viendront
gonfler les rangs de la base aérienne
normande un enjeu majeur avec 15%
d'effectifs supplémentaires sur la base
aérienne ces effectifs il faut à la fois
les intégrer en termes d'infrastructures
d'où les chantiers que vous voyez
derrière moi chantier qui concerne
l'escadron lui-même également
l'hébergement la capacité administrative
un ensemble de bâtiments qui vont être
construits c'est également tous les
fonctionnements l'intégration de moyens
de systèmes d'information et de
communication des donations qu'il faut
rendre compatibles et protéger bien sûr
c'est également la vie au quotidien la
restauration par exemple qui doit
prendre en compte ces 15 % de militaires
supplémentaires pour embrasser ce
nouveau destin la base aérienne change
de visage depuis 2019 des travaux
d'envergure ont été engagés bâtiment de
commandement parking avion centre
d'instructions et simulateurs sont en
cours de construction et pour cela des
entreprises locales sont sollicitées
comme la société celten depuis 35 ans
cette entreprise de céleri fabrique des
bâches sur mesure et des tapisseries
d'ameublement
sur le chantier elle réalise la façade
de 1000 mètres carrés du futur bâtiment
de commandement de l'escadron
franco-allemand alors là nous sommes en
train de préparer un gros chantier pour
la base d'Évreux vous voyez ici les
plans d'ensemble de la base et sur le
bâtiment que vous voyez ici nous allons
créer une façade textile un petit peu
déportée du bâtiment environ un mètre du
bâtiment façade qui est constituée en
fait de toiles une toile PVC enduites la
base aérienne vous a choisi parce qu'on
est implanté localement et nous avons vu
apporter des solutions techniques qui
ont séduit notre client plus une
expérience de 35 ans qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est assez reconnu dans
ce métier là tout à l'heure je vais à la
base aérienne le chantier de la base
aérienne a été confiée à plusieurs
sociétés pour toutes une opportunité en
pleine crise sanitaire montant de la
commande 56 millions d'euros
de la face
le ministère des armées il est
conducteur
au service d'infrastructure de la
défense qui assure la maîtrise d'ouvrage
délégués de ce chantier d'envergure le
ministère des armées c'est le premier
propriétaire foncier de l'État et il
doit s'adapter en permanence pour
accomplir ses différentes missions donc
il a un besoin très important en matière
d'infrastructure pour exemple en 2019 le
montant total des engagements de contrat
apporté par le SID a atteint 2 milliards
d'euros donc le SID est un acteur majeur
pour l'activité économique et l'emploi
et c'est effectivement les entreprises
de cale du BTP qui ont bénéficié le plus
mais pour accueillir 260 militaires
français et allemands les constructions
d'infrastructures ne suffisent pas
logement éducation travail des conjoints
il faut penser à tout ici dans la mairie
d'Évreux ce militaire allemand dispose
d'un bureau sa mission organiser
l'arrivée des familles allemandes à
Évreux ce matin ils s'entretient en
visioconférence pour faire un point
d'étape avec l'Allemagne
de elle est responsable de boucle
personnel qui est qu'elle va revenir ici
aussi en France maintenant il a préparé
une liste avec tous les soldats qui vont
venir avril mais août et octobre
et moi je trouve ça formidable parce que
maintenant je peux beaucoup travailler
avec la mairie pour accueillir les
familles
comment allez-vous ça va bien tout va
bien moi mon rôle ici c'est préparé
toutes les choses comment ça marche avec
les lancements comment ça se marge pour
ouvrir une compte de à la banque
contraire avec l'électrique internet gaz
ou tout ça on prépare déjà la liste pour
les élèves qui vont rentrer à l'école et
nous on a commencé les cours d'allemand
et les cours d'anglais ah oui pour les
commerçants
c'est une belle image pour Évreux et
l'arrivée de cette escadron va permettre
de mieux situer Évreux sur la carte va
donner envie aux gens de venir et passer
un week-end va donner envie aussi
j'espère aux Allemands de venir faire du
tourisme sur ce secteur c'est aussi un
millier de personnes femmes enfants
militaire qui vont venir consommer à
Évreux vivre à Évreux travailler leur
famille amener leurs amis sur hébreu
évidemment pour nous c'est un enjeu
énorme
si des bases montent en puissance
d'autres ont dû fermer leurs portes
[Musique]
c'est le cas de la base 901 de dragon
dans la région Grand Est
dans les galeries de l'ancienne ligne
Maginot enterrée sous le massif du
hoshwald la station radar de dragon 24
heures sur 24 2 escadron de contrôleur
aériens se relaient dans cette salle
d'opération pour assurer la mission de
surveillance de guidage et
d'interception dans la zone aérienne de
défense du nord-est de la France
étage de la guerre froide cette ancienne
base aérienne a été dissout en 2015 pour
compenser les impacts économiques et
démographiques de cette décision le
ministère des armées a mis en place un
dispositif d'accompagnement ambitieux le
CRSD le contrat de redynamisation de
sites de défense les actions de ce
contrat ont pour but de redynamiser le
territoire c'est-à-dire d'y recréer de
l'emploi et de l'activité localement
délégué à l'accompagnement régional
Nicolas représente le ministère des
armées dans le Grand Est ce matin il a
rendez-vous avec le président de la
communauté de communes du Pays de
Wissembourg territoire directement
impacté par la fermeture de la base
aérienne
et toute la partie basse on est comme
vous le savez on voit de
sessions à l'euro symbolique donc ça
c'est effectivement les actes
d'engagement vous ont déjà été en retard
l'environnement sont signés on a on a
simplement en attente décret de c'est ça
le projet
succession à l'euro symbolique la
réhabilitation de Dragon Ball représente
un investissement public de plus de 7
millions d'euros
un contrat de redynamisation pour avoir
des finances mais qui permettent de
monter un projet c'est à dire de faire
de cette fermeture une opportunité de
rebond économique pour le territoire sur
le site de l'ancienne base on trouvera
des entreprises des boutiques des
restaurants et même un parc aventure
tout ceci s'intégrant dans un projet
plus large autour du tourisme vert
comprenant des chemins de promenades à
travers les cimes des espaces de camping
et une tour d'observation de 30 mètres
de haut l'ensemble devrait accueillir
200 000 visiteurs par an et créé 130
emploi direct
pour l'instant l'heure est au démolition
en six mois 30 bâtiments ont été
détruits soit l'équivalent de 33000
tonnes de gravats 400 tonnes de bois et
250 tonnes de ferraille
avec 8 contrats de redynamisation de
site de défense actuellement en cours le
ministère des armées s'attache à
accompagner les territoires au plus près
des Français
[Musique]
les légionnaires qui viennent chercher
de la viennoiserie des baguettes ils
viennent au quotidiennement sortez là
depuis le mois d'août donc après on
commence à reconnaître des personnes à
pouvoir un petit peu discuter des fois
c'est un petit peu rigolo avec la
barrière de la langue pour certains mais
c'est toujours on finit toujours par se
comprendre et je crois qu'ils sont
gourmands ils aiment bien les
viennoiseries donc c'est très agréable
merci
c'est silhouette de légionnaires dans
les ruelles de la cavalerie font
désormais partie du décor de cette
petite commune de l'Aveyron de près de
1700 habitants
depuis 2016 les 3000 hectares du camp du
Larzac accueillent la 13ème demi-brigade
de légion étrangères la treizième dble
venue des Émirats arabes unis
c'est implantation de 1300 légionnaires
a donné un nouveau souffle aux
entreprises et commerçants locaux c'est
le cas de Séverine originaire de Corse
elle a suivi son mari légionnaire
affecté à la 13e DBLE et ouvert l'unique
boutique de fleurs de la cavalerie
comme il n'y avait pas de fleuriste à la
cavalerie que j'ai vu qu'il y avait que
des commerces de bouche j'ai voulu faire
mon commerce de fleurs bonjour et je me
suis installée ici grâce à la mairie de
la cavalerie qui m'a aidé à trouver
local m'a aidé à m'installer sans eux
j'y serai pas arrivé c'est de la belle
belle rose française en plus quand le
régiment là je suis à plein de turbine
mais quand le régiment est absent je
suis ralenti moi aussi on a un impact
direct et je pense que c'est beaucoup de
commerçants comme ça ici enfin tous les
commerçants la 13e des belles on en a
besoin d'un cavalerie si la petite
commune profite de la présence du
régiment c'est plus largement le cas de
toute la région
en seulement deux ans plus de 1400
emplois ont été créés dont 90% dans le
bassin de vie de Millau ici dans cette
boutique de sport de Millau nous
retrouvons le caporal chef Maxime Le
magazinier du foyer du régiment et vous
avez souvent des légionnaires qui
viennent dans votre boutique
du coup s'entraîner et ensuite ouais
toute la gamme
[Musique]
fidèle et c'est carré c'est toujours un
plaisir de le recevoir
je vois que vous des versions un diplôme
de la Légion étrangère vous pouvez me
montrer c'est quoi
c'est témoignage de reconnaissance qui a
été fait par le Bureau sport parce qu'on
a travaillé pas mal ensemble notamment
pour le cross pour les premiers cross
quand le régiment est revenu en fait il
y a eu besoin de coupe de trophées comme
ça un peu au dernier moment je l'aurais
livré pile poil dans les temps ça a été
très content donc voilà en plus on a
déjà dit que c'était assez rare que de
tel
témoignage de reconnaissance soit fait
donc j'en suis d'autant plus ravi merci
au revoir
qui est très bien qui fait des bons prix
pour la Légion donc on vient souvent ici
allez une fois par semaine on passe en
ville et si jamais on a besoin des trucs
on rentre et puis basket tenue de sport
voilà ils sont contents de nous voir
nous aussi d'ailleurs
et ça fait des bons relations entre nous
si de toute évidence les commerçants
locaux bénéficient de l'implantation du
régiment des liens de proximité ont été
noués avec les collectivités locales ce
matin l'officier supérieur adjoint du
régiment le commandant Marc-Antoine a
rendez-vous dans une annexe de la mairie
objet de la Réunion un problème
d'assainissement des eaux usées
elles sont fréquentes avec les
collectivités locales elles sont très
fréquentes puisque le régiment est
vraiment implanté sur la commune on est
on n'est pas du tout excentralisé ou
perdu dans la campagne et de fait les
liens avec la mairie sont extrêmement
proches depuis l'arrivée du régiment il
y a 4 ans
à la vue du treillis le maire de la
cavalerie ne manque pas de saluer
l'officier de ce régiment de Légion
étrangère devenu son premier administré
ça a été une grande chance pour nous en
2015 quand il y a eu l'arrivée de la
région c'était un camp qui était en mode
d'arrêt et d'un coup ça remue d'ailleurs
la population a doublée c'est une
évolution exponentielle que connaît la
cavalerie que toutes les communes du
monde voudrait la voir les gens c'est 25
ans donc beaucoup de jeunesse et
beaucoup de jeunes mariés ou en tout cas
en devenir et donc des familles qui ont
créé une demande en crèche une demande
en école aussi de base tout ça ça va
forcément se créer et arriver
en premier le jour que ce soit en termes
démographique ou économique
l'installation de 1300 légionnaires et
de leur famille a été une opportunité
inouïe pour cette commune qui a aussi du
renforcer ses structures d'accueil des
familles une des meilleures marques de
cette attachement à la commune ou à
l'Aveyron en général c'est que nos
légères s'installe et se marient avec
des aéronaise j'ai surtout célébré des
mariages du monde entier on a été obligé
de parler mandarin anglais bon c'était à
peu près espagnol on va pas la Rodriguez
j'ai pas eu de problème donc on a on a
fait je sais plus combien de mariages
c'est le nombre c'est exponenti au
niveau des au niveau administratif ça a
été quelque chose de phénoménal une
demande administrative exponentielle à
l'image de l'école primaire Jules Verne
située à seulement 1 km des portes du
régiment elle est composée d'un tiers
d'enfants de légionnaires en deux ans
deux classes supplémentaires ont été
créées pour les accueillir une facilité
pour ce sergent au 22 ans de service le
plus souvent en manœuvre ou en opération
c'est étonnant parce que même mes
enfants que j'allais en retourne en
Guyane ils veulent pas ils veulent
rester ici et surtout pour les trois là
ils ont jamais vu la neige donc pour eux
c'est une découverte donc non non ils
sont très bien intégrés au sein de la
population
oh là là
[Musique]
et le soutien en famille c'est très
important parce que sans eux donc je
pense pas que j'allais durer encore
longtemps dans l'armée mais tant que je
le soutiens de mon épouse
ainsi mes enfants donc oui oui c'est
important la famille c'est très
important
[Musique]
une implantation réussie donc à l'image
du lien indéfectible qui uni nos
territoires à son armée
[Musique]